vous avez tellement de trucs à vous
raconter vous avez 20 ans à attraper
Siam payant et Fabian bonsoir
alors
Siam payant et Fabienne gorge aucun
doute possible vous êtes jumelles et
pourtant il y a encore quelques mois
vous
ignoriez totalement l'existence l'une de
l'autre néo Vietnam en 1992 vous avez
été séparé puis adopté par deux familles
complètement différentes et 22 ans plus
tard grâce à Facebook vos destins ont
fini par se recroiser vous nous
raconterez votre histoire à 20h
[Musique]
Siam payant et Fabienne gorge remontoir
jumelles séparées à la naissance vous
avez été adopté par deux familles
différentes et 22 ans plus tard grâce à
Facebook vos destins se sont recroisés
alors vous êtes né le 4 mars
1992 à l'hôpital d'Arnold au Vietnam
abandonné par votre mère biologique qui
n'a pas les moyens de vous élever dans
quelques jours plus tard vous serez
adopté par des parents français alors
Siam vous serez adopté par Philippe et
Blandine Peillon un couple de chefs
d'entreprise de Lyon
et vous Fabienne par Thérèse et Jean de
nigorges agriculteurs à Mendy un petit
village à 75 km de Bayonne dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques voilà alors aux
deux familles l'hôpital fournit une
lettre d'abandon un document sur lequel
il est certifié que la maman n'a donné
naissance qu'à un seul enfant car à
l'époque le Vietnam autorise l'adoption
que d'un seul enfant par famille quitte
à produire de faux documents pour les
jumeaux en l'occurrence c'est ce qui
s'est passé alors vous grandissez dans
deux milieux entièrement différents Siam
à Lyon dans la bourgeoisie alors l'hiver
vous allez faire du ski dans les Alpes
l'été vous partez en vacances sur les
cinq continents enfin c'est une vie
assez agréable
ça va alors vous Fabienne c'est
différent un indice à la ferme il y a
des vaches il y a des brebis les
vacances chez vous on connaît pas la
seule fois que vos parents ont pris des
vacances c'est pour aller vous adopter
au Vietnam alors l'adolescence Siam vous
menez la vie dure à vos parents sans
savoir pourquoi vous vous sentez très
seul vous dites je détestais rester seul
chez moi c'est un peu comme s'il me
manquait quelque chose alors votre mère
vous emmène voir tout un tas de psys
ce mal-être se traduit par des
difficultés au lycée Fabienne alors vous
aussi vous traversez un malaise
inexplicable et à l'école c'est à peine
mieux que Siam hein
toutes les deux vous avez un sentiment
de manque
maintenant
on le dit on s'est retrouvé mais sinon
on savait pas faire l'accent des
Pyrénées-Atlantiques
c'est drôle
un jour c'est le 15 janvier 2014 vous
recevez Siam un message sur votre page
Facebook une amie vous écrit ma sœur
Marie m'a envoyé le lien profil facebook
d'une connaissance qui est ton sosie
regarde cette impressionnant et là vous
allez sur la page Facebook de Fabienne
au début j'ai cru que c'était une blague
quoi au début oui je suis allée voir je
pensais que ça allait être une asiatique
qui me ressemblait parce que tout le
monde dit les asiatiques se ressemblent
et au fait au final je trouve ça
Fabienne et là c'est vrai que c'était
assez troublant de me voir mais avec les
cheveux courts
de beauté le même sourire si vous fait
peur un peu non au début c'est vrai que
c'est un peu troublant mais bon on se
pose plein de questions et alors là vous
décidez d'écrire à Fabienne et là
Fabienne vous répondez aux questions de
de Siam avec une certaine méfiance
alors le visite date de naissance 4 mars
1992 comme moi oui mais moi j'ai été
adopté à un œil comme moi
donc j'ai décidé de l'appeler et puis là
on s'est posé plusieurs questions le
groupe sanguin alors Siam c'est vous qui
lancez cette phrase absolument
improbable c'est pas pour te faire peur
mais je crois qu'on est jumelles
alors maintenant évidemment le plus
difficile c'est de l'annoncer aux
parents alors Siam vous envoyez une
photo de Fabienne à votre mère et je
vous dis mais qu'est-ce que tu as fait
tu t'es fait couper les cheveux ou quoi
et oui mais normalement c'est pas moi
maman je crois que j'ai une sœur jumelle
et vous vous réveillez alors vous vous y
allez pas de ma morte vous réveillez vos
parents à 3h du matin leur montrer la
photo vous dites je crois que j'ai une
sœur jumelle ils ont réagi comment vos
parents mon papa m'a sorti à 3h du matin
de toute façon là-bas il se ressemble
tous
[Rires]
alors le lendemain les deux familles se
retrouvent sur Skype pour faire
connaissance et puis rendez-vous est
pris pour le week-end suivant Fabienne
donc vous allez à Lyon et là vos parents
ont peur que vous abandonniez en fait je
pense ouais et puis ce sont les
retrouvailles alors là vous tombez dans
les bras l'une de l'autre et quand vous
vous voyez vous ressentez un immense
soulagement un peu comme si tous vos
problèmes de l'adolescence d'un seul
coup était effacé
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est incroyable c'est que votre
complicité à ce moment-là cette nuit là
est instinctive quoi vous avez vous
retrouver quoi comme comme deux morceaux
de la même orange quoi c'est
extraordinaire et là vous décidez
d'organiser la rencontre des deux
familles alors deux mois plus tard pour
votre anniversaire à toutes les deux les
gorges reçoivent les payons alors
évidemment ça se passe dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques dans ce petit
village de Mendy alors tout le village
est en fait effectivement et il y a même
une messe spéciale en votre honneur
c'était mon papa qui avait organisé ça
il avait fait venir un des danseur une
chorale il a fait un gros apéro
mais une chorale
ensuite l'idée quand même c'est de
partir au Vietnam c'est de retourner
là-bas alors vous vous connaissiez je
suis déjà allée trois fois avant
vous faites connaissance avec votre pays
d'origine à travers l'association que
suhan créée par la mère de Siam donc là
vous voyez des enfants pauvres dans les
rues qui vendent des petits bracelets et
vous dites voilà peut-être qu'on serait
devenu
donc on a vraiment la chance d'être ici
d'avoir deux familles formidables et on
les remercie beaucoup voilà
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu